and on Friday University of
Massachusetts history professor Manisha
Sinha looks at the abolitionist movement
at Harvard bookstore in Cambridge
Massachusetts that's a look at some of
the author programs book TV is covering
this week many of these events are open
to the public look for them to air in
the near future
on book TV on c-span to
afterwards is next on book TV former
bush administration official John you
looks at the growth of presidential
power during the Obama administration
John you welcome to afterwards again oh
we were last year six years ago I
interviewed you for crisis in command
which was a wonderfully rich legal
history of five presidents and their use
of executive power I I loved I loved
reading it to prepare
I loved interviewing you and I even read
it again after after we had the
interview oh great yeah I hope you
bought two copies No and so c-span
called and said put what I interview you
for a book gave me the name of the book
and I just jumped at it
and then but last I found help
you didn't write the book but there is
good news and that is it's it's a
compilation of legal essays by 26 legal
scholars talking about various areas of
the executive branch again we're in the
executive branch mm-hmm so Liberty's
nemesis or really you know Liberty's
downfall a pretty dire pretty dire now
they tell me how it all came about and
what you did to put this together well
first thanks so much for agreeing to
interview me again and you've renewed my
desire to try to write even more books
faster so it's not once every six years
I would get a chance to meet together on
c-span this book came together because I
was trying to think about what
characterized the Obama administration
over the last seven years I wrote this
book about foreign policy crisis and
command and presidential power directed
in national security threats and maybe
at the growth of the presidency over the
last 200 years I think the story of the
Obama administration has been the just
untrammeled expansion of the
administrative state of the agencies of
the federal government as a whole and
when we look at the media sometimes we
see eruptions tiny signs of it here and
there lots of cases are collected in
this book but the real story is just how
large the government has grown over the
last seven years we might see it in
cases like the Obamacare statute we
might see it in the
here and there but it's a story that's
in almost every subject area where the
federal government acts today how did
you decide who was going to be part of
the 26 well we tried to look at each
major agency in each area of federal
regulatory power and pick people who we
thought were heavily involved with those
agencies or even had been the heads of
those agencies so for example criminal
law where you're the expert not me you
and your husband Joe de genève are some
of the great criminal lawyers in our
country right now
we picked Michael Mukasey the Attorney
General Federer and former filter and
former federal prosecutor at one point
so you couldn't think of a better person
and I said it's a or for gun rights in
the Second Amendment we asked Bob Barr a
former congressman former Libertarian
Party in command because in there you
talked about strong executive and we
discussed how the founding fathers
debated should we have one one person
energy we had multiple heads and they
finally decided on a strong executive
yes yes so back in that time there
weren't any agencies yeah there were no
agencies in fact George Washington
didn't even have a campaign he was just
kind of drafted and so he didn't even
have any cronies to put into a
government how did he house the
government
it was unbelievable actually I think the
whole federal government in the
Washington ministration was never larger
than 300 people mostly Customs
collectors at the ports mostly under the
command of Alexander Hamilton who could
you know there was this great quote that
Thomas Jefferson once said when he was
I'm sorry that John if I gave it away
the John F Kennedy gave two Nobel Prize
winners who are American had a dinner at
the White House and he said never have
so much brilliance and intelligence but
brought into the White House since
Thomas Jefferson died here by himself
the same thing is for Alexander Hamilton
never in our government has so much
ability and capability and intelligence
has been brought to administration since
Alexander Hamilton
set by himself in the Treasury
Department he really was the one who got
the government up and running but
Washington was a general so he came into
office and he organized the presidency
initially like a military command with
very for hit for cabinet officers
essentially state what we would now call
justice
Treasury he had them all report directly
to him as if he were a German and he
gave orders directly to them and they
carried them out right away and that
structure was the one we basically had
for much of our history until the rise
of this other kind of government I would
say this new administrative state and I
want to get to that in just a little bit
but I think first we ought to give the
viewers an example of some a kind of
agency misbehavior I want to talk about
operation choke point and that was
written by Chuck Cooper of Cooper and
Kirk he actually has a case in this so
that's why he knows knows all about it
he's a brilliant Supreme Court advocate
and he happened to have been with me in
the Reagan Justice Department so we go
back many many years what is operation
choke point according to Chuck in his
chapter in this book this is I think a
very disturbing program in the federal
government but one that exemplifies a
lot of the problems arising in other
places this is a area where the federal
government is trying to prevent access
to banking by disfavored businesses
these are not businesses that are
illegal they're perfectly legal and
Chuck's chapter he talks about several
but the one he focuses on are what are
called payday lenders and these are
people I guess who will these are
companies small businesses that will
give people an advance alone before
their paycheck well I wanted to start
talking about payday lenders but I
really want the viewers to know what the
list of these bad organizations are
because it's listed right here's next
Chuck says lest there be any doubt as to
its messaging on this issue
the FDIC that's the agency the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation then
published a list of high-risk industries
in which such disreputable merchants are
to be found
and ammunition sales hmm lottery sales
coin dealers now I represented a bunch
of coin dealers once before the IRS may
God forgive me that I ever practiced
sack salt but I did for the regulatory
thing and it was a regulatory issue and
I met these people they're so nice
they're mom and pop stores they barely
make a living and the IRS had written a
regulation that required them to spend
about five dollars worth of paperwork
for selling a dime and we had to get a
change but I mean firearm sales of gun
dealers pharmaceutical sales tobacco
sales and the payday and the payday
don't yeah this is the disturbing thing
about this and other areas of the
regulatory state there's no statute that
Congress ever passed going after these
different businesses Congress could
probably ban some of them out of
existence if it wanted to but Congress
hasn't
in fact I'd Frank yeah purposely allowed
payday loans in generally right as you
would know the criminal law is not to be
read to extinguish a whole line of
business unless it clearly says so
instead what happens is the
administrator is the FDIC in cahoots
with some of the other agencies
ultimately the Justice Department reads
a very vague law about and regulation
about protecting the reputation
reputation thanking industry what
reputation risk was originally well the
idea originally was that you didn't want
banks risking their reputation in a way
that might harm the stability of the
financial system right this whole idea
is just to protect the stability of the
financial system and so part that might
be what if these banks start lending to
industries which are very high risk and
so people might doubt whether the banks
are actually financially stable that I'm
not sure even as a matter economics is
some of the government's should be
regulating even if it is then the
government through this I think
interpretation that doesn't really have
any grounding and whatever Congress
wanted to do says we can stop banks from
regulating two industries which we think
have bad reputations like gun sales
tobacco sales the little coin dealers in
other words the depositor is the bad
person and ruining the bank's reputation
yes
borrowing money from them but the thing
that's troubling is as you can see if
reputation is the standard then it gives
the regulator's the freedom to pick and
choose the people they don't like that
they and that's been the story the Obama
administration in these other areas is
selecting certain individuals groups
businesses points of view for disfavored
and almost prosecutorial treatment using
the power of the government well tell
the technique so that the these banking
people use against the bank's how do
they squeeze the banks to go along
whether you directly go after the people
yes again this is just like what's going
on other areas
I think the regulator's would prefer
they never have to do anything formal
right they use the regulatory process of
reviewing banks of having to give them
the necessary approvals that they need
to do their own business they you know
there are these bank examiners who look
at the books and it's almost like they
nudge them without having to ever
formally pursue the bank in any way to
say you don't really want these people
don't they they say well listen if you
don't get rid of these payday loan
people we're gonna have some more you
might have trouble you might have to
look at you again we might have some
real difficulty proving your there's no
formal action ever if that's the other
thing they the bomb administration and
the Ministry of state has been in what
they do is they threaten the cutoff of
funds or something serious more
regulatory review something expensive on
businesses to coerce them persuade them
they would probably say but I think
coerce them into what they want them to
do yeah so so then we have we we have
the courts and we have Congress who
could fix it those are the only two
places Congress hasn't done diddly squat
has has Congress so we have to go to the
courts and that's what Chuck Cooper is
doing on behalf of a group of pay payday
lenders and it it's in District Court
here in Washington DC and it's going
forward on due process grounds but I
have a law school question I haven't
done the reading yet just like what my
students say well guess what industry is
not in cool
on the bad-boy list marijuana yes I know
I know that you would have thought since
it's against federal law to and it's not
only not included on the list but the
Obama Treasury Department in 2014
issued guidance to enhance financial
services for marijuana growers and
sellers I mean you can't make this you
really can't make this up
so wouldn't there also be an equal
protection really does show the I think
abuse of prosecutorial discretion
because as you also know the Obama
ministration is not enforcing federal
law prohibiting marijuana in some states
like California and Colorado now where
those states have by state law said that
marijuana usage either is medicinally
okay or just recreationally okay but
federal law doesn't create some
exception like that and so I think this
is an example you know this
administration apparently you're again
you're the more the expert on criminal
law and policy than I am but this
administration seems strangely Pro
marijuana legalization and so since they
favor that they're using operation choke
point to get at the agencies they don't
like like gun sales or you know a payday
lenders are not after industries that
actually are illegal but which they've
somehow frustrated favor which is
marijuana use and to show a prejudice I
want to end this with this with this
observation first of all whenever they
write to Congress they say payday
lenders and pornography dealers I mean
that's okay
they love them together but here's the
deal J official being quoted saying
we're changing the structure within the
financial system that allows these this
fraudulent and businesses and he says
we're choking them off from the very air
they need to survive I mean what is
government doing in that kind of
business I agree I agree ated that and
this again goes to other agencies as
well is that the government could if it
thought they were illegal prosecute them
directly but instead it's using the the
expense the bird ends the demands of the
regulatory state which regulates almost
all businesses now in the country of any
size it's using the threat of that the
threat of administrative action to
coerce people to get its way I think
it's I think it's not what the framers
had in mind
then seem to have done diddly-squat that
so let's turn to the courts and and just
see how the courts treat agencies and
what agencies do and the we discussed
the executives
authority how did we really get here in
you know Washington Jackson we're going
all along we don't have all these
agencies when did it start and how did
it start it's really interesting so as
we talked about in crisis in command
executive power really expands during
periods of crisis depends the name of
the book wars emergencies but when those
crises would pass the executive branch
was shrink and the government would
shrink Woodrow Wilson I think is really
intellectual father figure of the kind
of administrative state we have today he
saw the expansion of agencies and
government power during wartime and he
wanted to make it permanent you know he
wanted to make it last beyond Wars he
thought that was efficient government he
got those ideas actually from Germany
where he came to admire the Prussian
system of government administration you
know it was a lot of that really a very
influential political scientist before
he was president and this was his view
and then expanded by then FDR FDR though
was the one who made a permanent in the
crisis of the Great Depression he took
Wilson's ideas and Wilson's model and
made it permanent and that's those are
the agencies were still living with then
it got kind of supercharged by LBJ in
the Great Society programs and then I
would say President Obama is sort of the
last version of the great expansion that
we're living through right now that's
built on FDR and LBJ but then even far
it's like now we are on Great Society on
steroids you might have noticed that
they're all Democrats did you notice yes
well I think there's a big that is one
of the big different parts and
differences
well what were the Republicans doing I
grew up not hearing any kind of
conservative philosophy I grew up and
you presidents like Eisenhower was
praised and Nixon because why they made
government work there wasn't a
philosophy of government in fact Nixon
gave us the EPA so what what were
Republicans just doing all this time as
the Liberals were expanding government
well I think you're it's good to point
Eisenhower and Nixon because they tried
to make peace with the giant welfare
state that FDR and LBJ had created I
think you don't get a president who
really comes along to try to turn this
back or at least stop it until Ronald
Reagan and Reagan but it's interesting
some of the theories have come back
around
I think two-bike conservatives in the
end because Reagan came in he wanted to
deregulate he wanted regulations to be
lifted by the agencies to allow the
economy to grow faster which I think
happened but in order to do that he had
to demand that the other branches
Congress and the president give I'm
sorry Congress on the courts deferred to
what he was doing to give him more of a
free hand and so Reagan and his lawyers
of what you were one made the claims in
court you didn't make the claim but you
were one of arrogance Larry the radio
ministration in court came up what we
call the Chevron doctrine and this
Chevron doctrine said the courts should
basically defer to the agency so Reagan
could deregulate let's give a couple of
X about Chevron owes the Chevron case
because this was in the 80s and the
Reagan bureaucracy so to speak your
people in the EPA that abided by
Reagan's philosophy get busy and they
start writing a regulation that says hey
it's easier if you're going to change
your plant if you're going to build
something new or modify it and the
environmentalist came in said oh my gosh
you can't do that if you've got to be
tough and so then that goes to court and
what is the court exactly so in court
it's interesting the Clean Air Act
essentially gives the EPA the authority
to issue regulations just to make the
air cleaner consistent with you know
economic growth and safety and so on and
so it gives me pay huge discretion and
so when the EPA star
loosening some of the burdens of
regulation to allow faster economic
growth as you said outside groups
challenged and said you're disregarding
the statute by deregulating so the court
actually ended up agreeing with the
Reagan administration in the Chevron
case and it said we're going to uphold
this new EPA deregulatory rule because a
agencies are more expert than the courts
and so we should defer to the agencies
because they have more scientific
expertise and then two they said the
court said we should defer to the
agencies because they're part of the
presidency part of the elected branch
they're more accountable and responsible
in some way to the voters whereas we and
the courts are not you know we're
elected we're not elected and we have
our jobs for life and so there's no
accountability for us making policy
decisions of this nature and so in this
famous Chevron case from the early 80s
and ever since the federal courts have
fought at the margins but generally they
will defer them to agency rules that
taken in this area where so the Congress
estatic SAR kind of pretty much
ambiguous or give a large amount of a
power from Congress to the agencies well
what were the law is clear Chevron says
we're not that's the end of the story
it's where it's muddy where the law is
unclear now you would think that that
would be the most vulnerable place you
know we don't leave those those things
to the agencies and tell Congress to get
back with it yes you're quite right and
so the Chevron doesn't apply the statute
plain meaning is clear and you've seen
some very high-profile cases lately
where courts have been willing to say we
think the statutes clear most recent
examples King versus Burwell which
challenged the Obamacare subsidies to
individuals in states that didn't have
an exchange a state set up exchange but
generally most of the big statutes that
expand the power the federal government
excuse me everything's like the
securities markets the environment and
so on are quite ambiguous and are quite
vague and this is the area then if you
think about where the agencies are going
to do most of their work because that's
where they're going to have least
challenge at least plus pushback from
the courts
we mad at Congress for for wanting to
give up this power and and I've worked
in the on hill you've worked in the hill
yeah what I always observed with the
people saying yeah I want this and then
the other side would say I want that and
then you come together and you write
something that makes it look like you
got this and that at the same time no I
mean it you see how legislation goes and
especially in the legislative history
each side tries to write what they think
that was was passed which is why the
late Justice Scalia's I'm not looking at
legislative history yeah that's it it
doesn't mean anything
so the Conservatives like Chevron at the
moment cognitive is part as you said it
is partially Congress's fault because
Congress under the system our framers
created they wanted it to be very hard
to make law at all that's why the house
you have to get through the house and
the Senate two separate bodies elected
at different times with different
systems of representation and /
presidential presentment which he could
veto or he has to sign and then through
court interpretation that system is
really really difficult to get laws
through think about what we have now
which reverses that system Congress in
the 30s and then the 60s and then and
under the Obama administration passed
these very vague broad laws delegating
authority to the agencies those agencies
are constantly making law all the time
now Congress to stop them to stop
lawmaking which was supposed to be the
status quo under the framers system to
stop lawmaking Congress has to go
through all those hoops to pass a law to
stop the agencies from imposing more and
more burdens and regulations on us so
it's a complete upside down flipping
upside down of the framers
constitutional system today
conservatives would want to overrule
Chevron and say courts you get into it
and see whether this was at all
reasonable well this isn't interesting I
think struggle in the conservative world
of jurisprudence there are some who I
say would Justice Scalia for example was
quite a loyal fan of Chevron judge Bork
was as well the judge I clerk for judge
Silberman
the DC circuit which is I think the most
important administrative law court in
our country is also very wedded to
Chevron but in most recent years on the
Supreme Court itself you've seen Justice
Clarence Thomas who I also clerked for
has been raising doubts about Chevron
and in several opinions this last term
has questioned whether it should and
asked maybe should be overturned and I
suspect other was beginning to have his
doubts because he also was someone who
was raising doubts about it a
concurrences I met for example where
there applied to criminal law he was
raising doubts about whether it should
apply or not in the king versus Burwell
case or in this global warming case
Massachusetts vs. EPA I think it's I you
know it's move on to the IRS because
Chevron doesn't always apply I mean but
what the agencies can do doesn't
necessarily get addressed by Chevron so
we all know that Nixon the article of
impeachment for Nixon was he endeavoured
to obtain from the IRS confidential
information and tax returns to use in a
discriminating way but his IRS
commissioner said not not doing it
mm-hmm-hmm there's no doubt that the
obama administration used IRS rules to
Swart conservative groups in other words
to thwart the political process and and
i want to just give a little background
because of for the money in politics
that you know mother's milk
you don't last and we've had various
limits throughout the years of rules
about how you can contribute but the big
whammy was 2002 mccain feingold
um and in it was a provision that thirty
days before primary or 60 days before a
general election certain people could
not engage in political speech and
certain people were corporations
nonprofits and unions like huh isn't
isn't this a time that they are supposed
to be doing it it wasn't wasn't a rule
about contributing to the client that we
still are to the candidate we still have
that rule we have saw the 2700 or
whatever the limit is it didn't even if
these are third party groups that want
to speak out on an issue so like playing
parent
could not do an ad 30 days or 60 days
before an election flatly
unconstitutional I think on her free
speech and then what happened you know
like like water always finds a level
what money always finds a way to go in
527s sprung up in that aftermath and
those are political party things were
mostly liberal groups George Soros were
doing them because the rules were kind
of iffy and they weren't registering
with the Federal Elections Committee as
they were supposed to do and then
Citizens United comes along and what
citizens united was was a movie about
Hillary Clinton made during the 2008
campaign and it said bad things about
her because it was against her and they
were went to the FEC and said we want to
know if we're going to be put in jail if
we publish this and that's what the
whole whole case was about and I have to
point out something the irony when
McCain ran for president do you know how
much money he had available for to spend
because he used taxpayer didn't use
public finance II know I know I'm sure
it wasn't enough and Barack Obama 745
million because he didn't take the
taxpayer spending so you can see I'm
giving this information to see how the
political you know the Republicans
political veins were like exploding like
God we got it we've got to figure this
out
some way or another now I was at oral
argument I just have to tell you when
and the first the first time it was
argue I was there for the second one too
but the first time it was argued in here
with Scalia and Scalia says to the
Solicitor General now wait a minute I
want to know if I write a book four
hundred pages and on every page about
Hillary Clinton I just tell what
happened in her life and it's not it's
all neutral but on the last page if I
say don't vote for Hillary is that
banned by this yeah and you know what
the Solicitor General said yes Justice
Scalia and Scalia
purple and that's when the board said
come back we brief it and then we're
gonna do something else okay now that's
for January 2010 Citizens United comes
down what is it hold Citizens United
basically holds up money as speech and
so the government just like it can't
regulate the speech of private people
through these different groups and
politics it can't regulate the donations
to by private people or corporations or
used to these groups to be engaged in
politics as always I've always been
puzzled why critics of citizens united
and gets so upset about it because it
seems obvious to me the right answer so
just as I for example if we wouldn't say
the government for example has to have
recognizes the right to abortion but we
would never say Congress could say you
can't spend any money on abortions it
seems obvious that the government can't
regulate the money that you would use to
participate in a constitutional right so
citizens united simply says since you
have a right to free speech particularly
as you said in politics during campaigns
is when the framers really want to
protect the right of speech then how do
the government say ah but you can't
spend money on speak on using your
constitutional right if you could get
away with that and speech and think how
you could hollow out all of our
constitutional rights just by saying you
can't spend money on the on using your
right but the Democrats didn't like this
because it was going to equal the play
you feel but you know it's funny because
the studies as far as I can tell
actually show that citizens united in
effect would have a worse effect on the
supporters of the Democratic parties I
think it's unions actually who spend
more money than corporations on all this
but yeah I think they just got such a
burr under their set all about the idea
that corporations might be people but
Nelson his labor unions are people
including the president though trashing
the Supreme Court and thought you
falsely that he that it would allow
foreign corporations to spend without
limit in elections quote-unquote and
which is not actually true it was false
and that's when Sam Alito said not true
oh but it reminds me of Henry the second
and Thomas Becket who will rid me of
this meddlesome priest of course shortly
him Becket was murdered
and so there's Obama saying who will rid
me of this meddlesome citizens united
and guess who heard him the IRS yes so
talk about what happened in this chapter
we have article by lawyer and named Cleo
Mitchell who's also former state
legislator and she's been representing
these different groups that have been
applying for essentially for nonprofit
status from the IRS so that they could
take donations and then use them for
these kinds of purposes we've been
talking about and ira city they've been
denying them or slowing them down
without explanation usually these are
supposed to be pretty routinely granted
and supposed to be quick
some of them taken years and years
waiting having to apply for more
information having to provide
information which i think is
unprecedented in terms of the requests
from the IRS a who are your supporters
what are you spending what did you say
at your last meeting yes and so clida
and others and Congress started to ask
the IRS
why are you these groups seem to be
singled out are you singling them out or
are you actually also doing this to
groups which have different viewpoints
it turned out apparently that this was
only being done to groups that seem to
support conservative Clau causes or the
tea party groups and so on and not say
the Clean Water groups or union groups
or whatever and almost I think almost
without exception this is I think the
fruition of the fear that was as you
listed was behind the impeachment
article for President Nixon that IRS has
enormous discretion enormous ability to
ruin people's lives if it wanted to just
by asking to do an audit or to not give
you nonprofit status or permission that
you to undertake some activity imagine
what would happen if a president used
those for partisan purposes I think
everybody on both sides of the aisle
realize this would be terrible for our
democracy
and then as cletus shows officials and
the IRS didn't use their power or for
partisan purposes only to strike at
groups that they ideologically disagreed
with because they were using the
discretion and then
power the administrative state to punish
and to do with that I mean this is it
you can just sort things in the
bureaucracy without Chevron test or
rewriting some regulation you just put a
halt
yes just like operation choke point as
they're weighed out all the regulator's
can get a lot just by winks nudges being
slowed asking for more information they
can degrade a people's abilities to
exercise their constitutional rights and
it'll never show up in a court and
Chevron will never come into play but at
the end
clida makes recommendations on what to
do about it and every one of them is a
recommendation to Congress for Congress
to act yes
and I agree it's part of their spot we
should be clear you know both of us
working on the hill well all the
responsibility is with Congress not just
in giving these agencies he enormous
power to start with which was Congress's
ago decades and decades ago the people
who are in Congress now didn't pass
those laws but the people in Congress
now can pass laws to stop it to take
away the power and to conduct oversight
hearings and the whole people
responsible yeah they're not they're not
and part of there's a lot of reasons why
part of it is the voters don't demand it
perhaps voters sometimes worry more
about the pork that's being brought home
to the constituency to the district
instead of asking about are you
following up on the IRS or so on some of
its congressmen and congresswomen don't
have a individual incentive oftentimes
because this is not going to help you
get reelected this is not going to help
you raise money for your campaigns and
some of it has got to be the
congressional leadership you know they
see the IRS is an issue but they're not
pursuing the administrative state issue
after issue to pull it back I don't
think the Republicans know how to hold
hearings I truly don't mean they're not
facile at it at it they the the Benghazi
hearings are one of them I mean it was
almost a disaster and yet I had all
kinds of information about you know the
real simple concepts like the security
personnel went from thirty eight to nine
you know you can take that one away and
you just pound on it the whole time and
they don't they don't seem to know how
yes why do you think that is because
they should be just as good at it as
Democrats but I agree with you the
bottom line is I think
Republicans have report this part of
running Congress I don't know I've
always said different people come into
the Democrats they're people that really
are organized and they come from places
like universities and unions and places
and there were people work together as a
group maybe maybe not so much at
Berkeley with anybody but Republicans
tend to come there independent business
people and they've worked you know rant
a rancher from some of the ones out in
Montana they're fascinating different
individualist and so I think they come
with different attitudes towards
government but why that should keep the
Republicans from being able to conduct a
hearing I mean I heard that they were
looking at impeaching the Commissioner
of the IRS have you ever heard any more
about that you know there was some a
little Dingell of that but you know I
had it but that's one thing that the
Congress of either party can do to
restrain the Ministry of State would be
to start using the Pietschmann power not
at the presidential level or real thing
of it but at the level of cabinet
officers or even lower down I'm I'm
right for the the head of the IRS
because they're still hiding documents
let's turn to criminal mmm my baby yes
you have any criminal criminal laws
there are five thousand that's how I was
gonna say does anyone actually know how
he found he's gotta figure this
somewhere but the federal regulatory
laws are mind-boggling three hundred
thousand mm-hmm according to the
Michaels I whole and I know he's a good
researcher uh when we were in law school
we were told that the criminal laws were
supposed to be so carefully crafted
right because of fairness because the
person should know what kind of conduct
he is prohibited so let's talk a little
bit about criminal law and even though
it's not your expertise the law
professors going to know this stuff
hopefully you'll do more of the answer
but let's just give a primer to the
people listening malum in SE and malum
prohibitum
tell the difference between those so
there's some idea that there's some
things which are just bad by Nature
right that's malum and
bad bank robbery murder murder there's
something society should prohibit all
societies will basically prohibit then
there's other things which you could
think of is not obviously always bad but
which society chooses to criminalize and
so that's actually going to be more of
our criminal laws today as you said I
think we start out as a common law
system with a simple clear set of
criminal laws mostly malam and say and
now we've got use of 300,000 criminal
provisions in federal law alone on top
of the ones in state law those are not
all you know evil by nature axles like
all governments are going to prohibit
and then talk about mens rea ax and
string viability because that's another
criminal law concept yeah this is
another thing where you've seen this
huge expansion of the administrative
state it used to be the idea that you
had to have a certain state of mind mens
rea ax a state of mind that you intended
to carry out a crime right so if you you
know if you tended to kill someone
versus someone died because you had an
accident is it a difference then in the
law particularly in these regulatory
errors there's this idea of strict
liability criminal law where it doesn't
matter whether you had an intention or
not just if the act resulted you're
going to be held guilty of a criminal
act that's I think another revolution in
the law and one again that's not the
system we started out with but is a key
underpinning of the regulatory state and
its use of criminal law today and then
there's one other factor in the criminal
law and that is the doctrine of lenity
yes tell us about that well this is a
this is this has got to be the criminal
defense attorney which you are now
favorite part and this was the idea it
goes back to the idea you start out with
that the criminal laws were supposed to
be few and clear and we could as
citizens could understand what it was we
could and couldn't do and the rule of
lenity meant that if law and it's very
tied in this idea of void law criminal
law shouldn't be vague if the criminal
law didn't really clearly tell you what
was illegal
there were two you used you know it's
ambiguous or it was not clear as to what
you could have couldn't do then the
government the courts especially but
also prosecutors should employ what's
called the rule of lenity to be generous
and it's almost that ties are even
things that were close should be counted
in the defendants favor that you
shouldn't read the laws in the criminal
era to be to be expansive and to reach
things that it clearly didn't because
what cutting us the idea that we should
be able to citizens to be able to tell
what we are and not allowed to do
because criminal punishment and
consequences are so severe and harsh a
complete opposite of Chevron deference
exactly exactly in the eye I think this
is something that Justice Scalia and
Thomas have raised questions about it's
not clear to me that Chevron should
apply a criminal law at all I how could
they possibly yeah how could it possibly
and I have a dissent mm-hmm he's going
to be known later as the great dissenter
don't you already taken did say he did
say in the past year he's just really
getting tired of writing dissents oh
really
yeah you know just if just I mean it's
terrible that you know that's passing
but it does give us a chance to
appreciate him and I mean not many of
his greatest opinions the ones you
remember best unfortunately I would say
fortunate fortunate art dissents there's
nothing I think he should have been
proud of the dissents I mean I think the
Morrison versus Olson dissent where he
said the Independent Counsel was
unconstitutional remember that he yeah
he was eight to one you know seven to
one and he has that great line he said
sometimes you know threats to the
separation of powers are wolves in
sheep's clothing and he said but this
one is a wolf dressed like a wolf in his
language but may put them in a way I
mean no big words they were all just
brilliant creative concepts but he says
here the rule of lenity requires
interpreters to resolve and begin guity
in criminal laws in favor of the
defendants and he says the not to do so
would turn their normal construction
upside down replacing the doctrine of
lenity with a doctrine of severity yes
which is a great club yes and I think I
think he's right as a matter of the
original reading of the law that Chevron
itself is not constitutionally required
it's just a rule of judicial policy it's
the courts good idea for themselves
about how to approach reading vague
statutes I totally agree with you and I
think with him that that makes no sense
an air criminal law where the idea is
not that the court should defer to
agencies but there's another more
important constitutional value which is
that due process requires a criminal
defendants and citizens have the ability
to tell what it's illegal and legal and
the seng appoint I would make there's it
does it goes back to this point you
raised earlier that there are
conservatives now questioning whether
Chevron was a good idea and so in
different eras they were like in the
criminal law
trying to cordon off areas that they
thought would be immune from Chevron and
maybe eventually Justice Scalia had he
lived longer would have thought for sure
I read that I couldn't even believe the
court would even think of giving Chevron
deference
the other end of it is Justice Breyer I
would say is probably the person most on
the other side of this point what he
thinks of the administrative state as a
sort of ration a super rational
efficient manager and so Congress this
meddlesome untidy well it's almost like
a black box things go in things come out
who knows what happened in that black
box and it's the agencies and the
president and all you know the executive
branch of government that's going to
make a harmony out of everything and
engage in efficient regulation so that
group would say oh you should have
Chevron deference for everything they'll
make it all work out even the criminal
laws because Congress is passing all
kinds of crazy things someone has to
smooth it all out make it work in
harmony so they would say why should
criminal law be different but I think I
agree there's a constitutional principle
of due process it well let's see how it
worked out for somebody named Lawrence
Lewis do you remember that okay yeah
grew up in the DC project's started out
as a janitor worked his way up to be the
chief engineer for Norwood I happen to
know know what it's by near our house
it's a retirement home for military
persons or spouses of military persons
in a lot of elderly people there of
course it's a retirement home and they
were flushing their diapers adult
diapers down the toilets which was
causing a problem backing up into their
rooms and so he Lawrence decided that he
should divert it to what he thought was
a sewage drain which he thought went to
a sewage plant
but alas did not it went to Rock Creek
and then to the Potomac and the Justice
Department went after him charged him
with a felony and admitted that they
didn't even that he didn't know what he
was doing
yeah unfortunately that case is probably
like thousands of cases where the
government is overreacting and this is
something that you should be able to
solve by a common sense you know the
government just say this you made a
mistake you know just fix it there's no
you didn't tend to do it instead the
government comes down against this poor
guy with criminal you know criminal
sanctions because they can because they
have that kind of discretion because
they know they're going to escape
oversight because they know that they
expect the course that defer to them and
so unfortunately the book is full of
examples of cases like this well let's
go to the Lacey Act a guy named Lacey it
was a member of Congress and they passed
a law to protect the wildlife in the
United States that sounds ok all right
but then in 2008 and guess who
controlled Congress in 2008 yes it was a
Democratic Congress they expanded it to
protecting plants but not just
protecting United States plants but
everybody's plant everybody's plans
throughout the world so you can't do you
can't import something a plant that is
in violation of some other countries law
and do you remember the story about the
three men and women who well this has to
really it's really actually has to do
with whether you could import certain
kinds into the United States or not and
whether and this was completely
turned out to be legal under the laws on
earth but this was according to the EPA
regulators illegal under American law
and so these poor people were prosecuted
too for basically important the wrong
kind of seafood instead of boxes or
something like yeah who knew and
evidently Hondurans didn't even know
because the they didn't care a court
said later in under and that law is not
illegal or the issue but the the three
guys got six years and the woman got two
years incredible and so you have to ask
yourself why you know there's so many
this is the other thing that's all
others there's so many problems in our
country so many things that do demand
government attention why has the
government sending its prosecutors after
people just because they're wrong
Berkeley where whether you have paper
bags and plastic bags seems to be one of
the most important public policy
questions it's time to face mankind
although this is a Montgomery County in
Maryland and if you you have to buy a
bag so we've gotten used to carrying our
bags into the drugstore in places Oh
Gibson guitar oh gosh another incredible
case yeah armed federal agents went into
Gibson guitar plant in Tennessee and
said give me your wood and your guitars
because you are using wood and some of
your guitars they're in violation of
Madagascar and India law it's from an
endangered tree it's not even clear
whether he even knew but I'm sorry
guitars new way that wood was coming
from he said quite clear if I knew these
trees were endangered of course and they
weren't you know their import was ban of
course I never would have used them to
construct his making custom guitars
essentially right and so again why does
the government have to use the power of
criminal sanctions essentially
destroying the destroyed should destroy
his business yes you know jobs in the
United States which were supposed to
favor of this administration and
Congress produced again it shows that
the government has so much power that
they can use it
flagrant lee haeri oh my arbitrarily
almost but in ways that are so run
against common sense it shows how out of
control the administrative state has
become when this has become routine do
you know the Dana wall of what happened
no what happened to the poor guy in the
end they reached a deal a few years ago
and Anne Gibson guitar settled for three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars but
in and that's cheap change for if you
were representing him I'm sure that the
government would have had to pay him but
they got their materials back they got
their wood back and they could still
continue to buy wood from India so you
go like scratch your head so what was
the point of it all yeah
why why did why did we do this on that
and then I want to bring in a client a
fine night so I will do a personal story
but it's very similar but it wasn't a
criminal case it was it was a civil case
but it was you know disastrous for them
for a few years um compounding
pharmacies do you know what compounding
pharmacies I hope never to know what
they are in the drug business because
some people can't take big pills I hate
those because and so they can make they
make them in different forms for people
or not everybody is supposed to be
taking medicine in the exact measure
that they are sold to the masses so
really neat compounders to do special
mixing I mean is there like the old
pharmacy oh um a very important part
well of course they mix controlled
substances so they have to have a DEA
license for a controlled substance and
that's all well and good
DEA wrote rules for you have to name the
patient sounds reasonable
then accept my compounding pharmacy was
for veterinarians and ER DEA had not
written any rules for veterinarians and
it's a whole different kind of business
because veterinarians they're kind of a
walking pharmacy and they go to the farm
and they see who's got a problem and
instead of writing the name of the
patient down they wrote the
my client wrote the name of the vet and
as we argued in one place what were they
supposed to write down yeah Nelly stick
this sketch number five and so DEA came
in armed taking documents showing the
the records that showed that they were
only naming the veterinarian and not the
not to her not the patient revoked their
controlled substance license
we went and that's where we when we came
in and we go to the court of appeals and
the Court of Appeals we win but do you
know how we win because I'm telling the
story because it's really interesting
for people to understand the court
didn't say give him back their license
courts don't do that
they said DEA huh no that's kind of a
problem work it out yeah and we were we
were happy with that we was a call can
we work it out
no go pound sand you're gonna go through
an administrative hearing which took
another three or four months and of
course lots more money this $350,000
when I look good had to be brought into
I mean we didn't formed a team and then
after the administrative law hearing it
took another year and the administrative
judge had still not ruled an
administrative judges are like that a
lot and they just sort of suck up to
this the agencies which is and there's a
case at the Supreme Court about this and
and we finally threatened a mandamus and
guess what our client got the license
back when we drafted him and Davis
instead we're filing this next week if
you don't give us our license not tell
tell everybody would have been in Davis
is essentially read a mandate that goes
back to the original famous case of
Marbury vs. Madison which Chief Justice
Marshall found or inferred the right of
judicial review it's essentially an
order by a court to a government
official saying carry out your legal
duty okay so at some point the yeah the
DEA realized that you were in the right
and they were just giving you a hard
time slowly you know keep as we saw in
other cases slowing things down
punishing people they may not like
without ever formally doing anything in
this case they were supposed to give the
license is quite clear and they just
decided to take their time
and doing it which every day right then
you don't get a license like that as a
day you can't that your client can't
work and the thing is you can't go to
the court you know you can't go crying
to mommy and daddy he's been bad until
it reaches such a time period that it
really looks oh yeah think about your
client does the unusual one many people
will not have the fortitude or the
resources to hire well-known criminal
defense lawyers and fight it in court
right they might just say please just
tell me whatever I have to do to keep my
business going which means for every
case like yours there's dozens of cases
of people that never see the light of
day who suffer from Liberty's nemesis
here is a great example of the title of
the book and cannot just carry out you
know perform the business if they want
to it's not harming anybody but which
doesn't fit the priorities of this
government I don't think I forgot to
mention that this client of mine the
pharmacy had advertised opposing the
government on some issue prior to all
this guy such a heart oh my isn't that
scary I wouldn't end up the the criminal
conversation was something about Scalia
isn't I can get through it yeah you know
I think the image and the American
people are oh he's a conservative judge
that means he's going to send everybody
to jail because that's what
conservatives do and it wasn't he was a
textualist I mean he looked at the text
of the Constitution and said well this
is what it says no I don't know I'm not
I might not like to burn the flag but I
have to allow people to burn a flag and
he told me that one of his proudest
cases was Crawford versus Washington do
you know the case no the criminal case
just a criminal case and it is a
requirement that there has to be
cross-examination of somebody and
out-of-court statements you can't so in
other words the lab technician that says
it was cocaine yes that lab technician
has to be in court for cross-examination
and she says great never in a
confrontation closet you as a defendant
have the right to see your accuser and
the witnesses and sometimes I meant he
wasn't willing to go along with putting
up shields in front of people even if
they were kids or vulnerable people
because he said the Constitution says
Wakasa
tution oxf says another I was going to
say another great line of cases where I
think Justice Scalia and I think Justice
Thomas too also went along with a more
libertarian view criminal law was the
idea
you know these cases they common in case
getting it's called Booker where you
know juries have to be able to make the
decision on all facts that have to do
with the conviction of somebody for a
crime and that judges can't do it for
them this had the effect of essentially
potentially meaning that thousands of
people who could have been convicted
under laws would now have to be retried
or they would have to have their cases
stopped on appeal and go back to trial
because judges were getting too involved
in too controlling of the criminal
justice process is variable and one
Morrison I think is we're talking about
these days I don't know what you think
about the apple the Apple FBI fight but
Justice Scalia and several other
conservatives are much more favorable
about privacy rights in the face of new
technologies that many people might have
expected maybe probably that I would
have been so the two cases I would point
to is the police officer who's gone
around the neighborhood with a heat
detection device to try to find
marijuana well now we know they can get
a lot of money if it raise a lot of
money from banks from her and Justice
Scalia said that's a search even though
we never entered the house and it
usually was you know the entrance of the
house that was seen as the the Fourth
Amendment protected space but not the
public's what you could see from a
public street and then the other one was
a GPS tracking case where police had put
a GPS tracker on someone's car and even
though you could have physically
followed the car in person and that
would not be considered a violation of
privacy for it to follow suspect Justice
Scalia joined with other justices to say
but putting the GPS tracker on the car
was an invasion of privacy so you know
as you said that I this stereotype of
liberal and liberals I think some of
them are on the other side of this cases
so the idea that liberals are favored of
criminal defendants and conservatives
like Scalia or Thomas where a favor of
the government is not true but
definitely not true with the
new world of privacy I don't know how he
would have come up on the come out on
the Apple case for example I could see
him I could easily have seen Justice
Scalia voting on Apple side even though
I personally I would think the FBI has a
better the argument here well I mean
just you know what not to get too far
off on that but it just amazes me why
it's it wouldn't ruin the phone belong
to the county so in the county saying
hey take it I don't understand why it's
such a big issue I mean I would think
that this would be better handled on
another set of facts where it's a person
as young as the privacy privacy right
but they're they're going out there full
full force one last area immigration mmm
written by the Chavis it was a
syndicated columnist and um it's a major
issue it was a major issue in the 2012
campaign and now of course it's it's
coming again but here here's the
political context and I really want you
to comment about what the President
Obama did because this isn't an agency
this is the big man did it
he spent year saying you know I'm not
the Emperor I with respect to the notion
that I can just suspend deportations by
executive order not the case and you
said that like two dozen times mm-hmm
and then in 2013 there was a Democratic
Senate and Republican House Democratic
Senate Senate passed a comprehensive
immigration bill and then the
Republicans got it in the house and so I
think they were sort of saying eh we
think we're going to get a better Senate
in 2014 we're not going to deal with
this we're not ever going to deal with
this because it's too tainted we don't
like it oh and in 2014 they indeed D get
a Republican Senate but not 66 votes so
anything just the Republicans were going
to work out together was not going to
pass the White House correct so they buy
the very situation
Republicans and Democrats then had to
negotiate for something you get a little
I can I get a little more maybe even you
go get something
President Obama did that I've got the
pen right after those midterm elections
and didn't even give the Senate in the
house a chance to work on legislation
yeah yeah I would say you know a lot of
the stories in this book are where the
president has just unleashed the
agencies isn't really monitoring them in
their stories of agency abuse because
agencies are going off on their own as
you said this is a different kind of
case this is a case where this really is
the president at the top and this is
going to be his I think his
constitutional legacy it may not be the
one that he wanted but I think it will
be his major effect on our separation of
powers and our Constitution and that's
his claim that he is the right not to
enforce the law when he disagrees with
it that's totally different than other
presences
I don't like the immigration quotas I
don't like the priorities immigration
laws set out he's not saying the law is
unconstitutional as we talked about
crisis in command presidents have often
struggled about if they think a law is
unconstitutional they might not enforce
it goes back to Thomas Jefferson in fact
this is different no one says the
immigration laws are unconstitutional
here everyone admits Congress has the
power they get to set how many people
stay in the country they get to decide
the criteria for deport you removal is
the legal term now not deportation or
not and President Obama just came and
said I don't agree with the the statute
is written I want there to be a more
generous immigration policy I would like
there to be a more generous immigration
policy I think Linda Chavez wants to
have a more generous inspiration policy
but the way you can't do it is for the
president just say I'm going to achieve
it just by saying I want more people in
the country so I'm just not going to
remove people who are here illegally
because I just disagree with it that
that is unprecedented even Richard Nixon
did it go that far
even I President Lincoln who I think is
the most expansive user of presidential
power never went that far and so I think
that is really an unprecedented